The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JEREMY KEPNER: All
right, welcome everybody.
I'm really pleased to
see you all here today
for what will be the first of
a nine lecture course called
signal processing on databases.
And this is a really
special day for me
because this sort of
represents a big step
in a set of technology
that I've been working
on for a couple of
decades, and really
been working intensely on for
the last three or four years.
And this is the
first course on what
we hope will be
a technology that
will become very widely used.
It is a completely unique
course on a completely unique
technology, so I
want to thank you
for being the guinea
pigs of this course.
It's hard enough just
doing a new course
on an existing topic.
Doing a new course on a novel
topic is quite a challenge,
so we're going to be trying
a few different things here.
There are going to be
certain topics covered
from more than one
angle, and we'll
see which ones sort of make
the most sense for you.
The first thing
I'd like to do is
talk a little bit about the
title of the course, which
is a little bit different.
The title is signal
processing on databases,
which is not two phrases, signal
processing and databases, that
are usually connected
together very often.
And so, signal processing,
as we all know,
is, here at Lincoln Labs,
one of the most core things
that we do.
In terms of the technology,
it's almost difficult
to imagine a technology that's
more core to what we do.
The only thing I could think of
was systems engineering, maybe.
But signal processing is really
at the heart of what we do.
Mathematically, signal
processing really,
the heart of that
is detection theory.
How do you find things?
Given sets of data,
how do you eliminate
things you're not looking
for and find the things
that you are looking for?
And then, mathematically,
the heart of detection theory
is linear algebra,
and so, just a show
of hands how many people
have had a linear algebra
course in there?
See, that's really awesome.
See at Lincoln,
that's probably--
this one a few
places in the world
where it was pretty unanimous.
You know, there's not too many
places where that's the case.
And so this technology is
really designed for you,
because it really assumes a
foundation in linear algebra,
and that's not as common
as you might think.
And so people who haven't
had linear algebra,
it's much harder for them to
take advantage of the ideas
that we're going to talk about.
So signal processing, detection
theory, linear algebra,
that's sort of the root
of the first phrase.
The second phrase,
databases, when
we think of databases we
think of typically, maybe
things that you do, searching
on the web, texts, maybe
other things like that,
which is not necessarily
consistent with the mathematics
that we think about when we
think about signal
processing, detection
theory, and linear algebra, we
naturally go onto real numbers,
matrices, those types of things.
So what we're
really doing here is
we're connecting that
mathematics with sort
of a whole new branch of data.
Words and strings
and relationships.
And so that's kind of the
really novel piece of it,
and it's really the core
idea that we're bringing here
is we're going to bring all that
machinery that we know so well,
and we're going to
try and apply it
to this new area which
is becoming increasingly
important for us.
So that's the
explanation of the title.
That's how we picked the title.
There's other
titles, and so I just
wanted to spend a
little time on that.
An enormous number of people
have contributed to this work.
This is a list of the
people that I could remember
at the time that
I typed the slide,
but no doubt I have
forgotten somebody important,
and so I apologize for that.
But certainly these
people, and the whole team
have been very instrumental
in allowing this technology
to move forward here.
So this is going
to be the outline
for this particular lecture.
And there's going to
be a rhythm to most
of these lectures,
which is there's
going to be a lecture, which
is going to be PowerPoint--
I apologize, we all see
plenty of PowerPoint--
mainly to introduce ideas.
And then there will be
sort of a demo, which
will go through code
that is actually
available in your
LLGrid accounts now,
and some of that
code will even be
part of homework
assignments, if you so choose
to do the homework assignments.
And so that's going
to be the flavor.
We'll do the slides,
we'll take a short break,
and then we'll do the
examples and talk about them.
So let me talk about
some of the kinds of--
and I stole this slide--
let me talk about some
of the kinds of data that
the technology that we're
going to be talking about
today really, really enables.
It allows us to
deal with data that
has to do with
relationships, relationships
particularly as those
represented by graphs.
So for example, you might
have vehicle tracks.
Those represent relationships
between locations.
A car goes from one
place to another.
That's a relationship
between those locations.
Another is social networks.
You know, everyone wants to
know who their friends are,
how many friends they are, who
they're friends of friends are,
those types of things.
So that's another type
of set of relationship.
Again, very textural and
oriented, very much oriented
towards words and not numbers.
Another area is cyber
networks, a very apropros topic
that people are, at least
everyone is impacted by,
and many people are doing work
on, which is relationships
between computers, communication
between web servers,
those types of things.
And again, that is a very
important area for us.
Just to give you sort
of a big picture here,
like well, why am I even here?
Why do I care about this?
What are the things
that we can do?
I'm going to kind of walk
through an example of some
of the things that we have
used this technology for that
have been very exciting for us.
And so, trying-- and
we'll have examples
like that throughout
the course, you
know, how you can
actually use this,
how this has had
really a real impact.
And so the first one
we want to talk about
is some work we've done
in the cyber domain.
So here's an example
of a data set,
which is a graph
that is web traffic.
And so, if we see here,
this is the source IPs.
So, you can imagine these
are the computers that
are on the inside
of some domain,
and then these are
the destination IPs,
all web servers that they hit
are the green ones around here.
This is sometimes referred
to in graph theory
as a bipartite graph.
It's basically
two separate sets,
a vertices that
talk to each other
but have no, at least
in this data set,
we are not recording any
connections within the sets.
And then, hopefully you can
see here these faint blue lines
here that are the actual
connections that show you
which of these
computers are connecting
to which of these computers.
There's obviously a lot
of data, web traffic data.
There's enormous amount of it.
It shows 90 minutes of data,
and in this particular case
there was actually
malicious activity
that we were looking to
detect in this data set.
So one of the biggest challenges
that you have in any data
set like this is
data representation.
And sometimes in
database parlance
this is called the schema.
So how you represent
your data is usually
if you can figure
that out, you're
almost halfway to
solving the problem.
And so, given
that, in this case,
we wanted to use
graph techniques,
we discover that our
data almost always
doesn't come to us in
a nicely formed graph,
and so we have to go
through a lot of steps here.
And so one thing you'll
see is with this technology
is that there's almost always
possible part of a pipeline
from raw data to conditioning
the raw data to inserting it
into a database to doing
analytics to doing queries
and other types of things.
You're always really going
to be using a pipeline.
And you're going to be wanting
to use different technology
tools for different
stages in the pipeline.
We're not in any way
trying to suggest
that the technologies
we're talking about today
are the only pieces.
It's an important
piece, the technologies
we're talking about, but
they're not the only pieces.
And you're always
really functioning
in the context of a pipeline.
So this just shows
the technology
stack that we will
be leveraging,
that we typically leverage
in these types of things.
Ultimately, our goal
is to get up here
to these graph analytics.
One of the things we'll
be talking about most
in this course is the
high level languages
that allow you to essentially
do graph analytics very easily
and bridge between the
databases themselves,
and the high performance
computing that you will need.
So again, not only do you have
a pipeline of software and data,
you have a pipeline or
stack of technology.
So when you're addressing
problems like this,
usually you're
starting at one place
but you will almost always,
when you build a system,
work out and deal with
these other types of things.
So that's sort of just a
quick overview and example
and I don't expect any of you--
it's probably just kind of,
the purpose of the
example's probably
to raise more questions.
Well, how do you really do this?
So now I'm going to sort of
take a bit of a right turn
here and really talk about
what the course is about, OK.
And I'm going to actually
talk about the course
a little bit of a big picture.
And I always felt that
every course should tell you
why that course is the most
important course you'll ever
take in your career.
You know, I think
every single course
you can come up with
an argument for that,
but people don't say it.
So I'm going to tell
you why this course is
the most important course
you will ever take.
Of course, every course is
the most important course
you'll ever take, but I'm going
to tell you why this one is.
So stepping way back,
we're all part of MIT here
and MIT has a
formula for success.
MIT is the number one
science and engineering
university on earth.
We can actually, by
any reasonable measure
that is true.
And in fact, by the people who
track this, it's true by a lot.
And so you know,
it's a real honor
to be associated with
this organization,
to be at an organization
that's at its zenith.
And MIT has had this incredible
run of success over the last 60
years because fundamentally
they recognize the formula
for making discoveries is
a combination of theory
and experiment.
Bring those two together,
and as an organization,
we've actually
organized ourselves,
MIT is organized around this
formula in that we have theory
and experiment, and theory
is the academic part
of the mission.
That's run out of departments.
Typically, it
involves mathematics.
This is a place-- I
mean, everyone here
raised their hands
to linear algebra,
and I can go to any part of
MIT and that will be true.
We probably have the highest
mathematical literacy
of any organization on earth,
and that's a very powerful,
powerful capability.
The mathematics that we use,
they become manifest or real,
typically in the
forms of algorithms,
and our algorithms become
real in the form of software.
Likewise, on the
experimental side, you know,
that's the research
that we conduct.
MIT actually has
large laboratories.
Laboratories that are fully
peered with the departments.
That is actually
quite a unique thing
for an academic institution
to have laboratories
and laboratory heads
that are right up
there with the department heads
in how they're positioned.
Lincoln being the largest of
them, CSAIL, the Media Lab,
there's a number of them.
So we have this thing.
And the focus of
research, of course,
is measurement,
which is data, which
often gets reduced to bytes.
And so, often implementing
this MIT formula
comes down to marrying
software and bytes together
in a computer.
That's sort of where we bring
these two ideas together.
And so we're going to be
talking a lot about that.
Implementing software
bringing bytes together
analyzing together that's where
these two things come together,
and I think that's
really, really important.
Now what's the tool we use?
What's the machine that we
use to bring these together?
It's a computer, all right.
And nowadays, computers
have gotten a little bit
more complicated than the way
we used to think about them.
We used to think
about them typically
as a von Neumann
machine, which means
you had data and operations,
you know, bytes and software.
And the bytes go into
a part of the computer,
they get operated
on, they come out.
And that model is still
true at a high level,
but the computers we
tend to deal with now
are much, much, much
more complicated.
So on the left is a
standard parallel computer.
Almost every computer used
today looks like this.
You have processors,
you have memory,
you have some kind of
persistent storage,
you have a network
connecting them together,
and this form a very complicated
what we call memory hierarchy.
It begins with registers
here at the top, caches,
local memory, remote
memory, and then storage.
And these are the units
that go between them.
And there's a lot of
implications of this hierarchy,
in terms of what
things are-- you know,
bandwidth goes up as you go
this way, latency goes down.
Programmability generally
goes up the closer you are.
You don't have to
worry about things.
And likewise, the
capacity of data
goes down as you go traverse
this way in a hierarchy.
So all modern
computers that you use
are these von
Neumann architectures
with multi-level
memory hierarchy.
And fundamentally the
thing you have to know
is that this architecture
selects the algorithms you use.
If algorithms are not going to
run well in this architecture,
you probably don't
implement them.
So one has to be very much
aware of one's algorithms
with respect to
this architecture,
because if you pick algorithms
that aren't going to run well
in this architecture, it's going
to be very, very difficult.
The goal of this
course is to teach you
techniques that will allow you
to get your work done faster.
And so this is a rather
complicated drawing here,
but this shows, given a
problem that you want to solve,
if you implement it
in software using
a variety of techniques,
what the performance
of those techniques is.
So in a certain sense, you could
view this as the volume of code
that you have to write
to solve a problem.
And then we have implementing
the program and C
as a reference point.
So as you move over
here and you do
things like in assembly
or Java, MapReduce,
you end up writing more code.
If you move over here and
do things in C++ or Java
or MATLAB, you write less code,
and this shows you the relative
performance.
Again, as you do
things in lower level
environments like assembly,
you can get more performance.
And as you do things in higher
level environments like MATLAB,
you get less performance.
And this is a fairly general
trade off space here.
If we add parallel
programming models here,
of which there is many, we
have direct memory access,
we have message passing, we
have a manager worker style
or map reduce style, we have
a whole different styles
of programming here.
We're going to want
to try and be here.
We're going to want to do
things that take less effort
and deliver you
more performance.
And so, we are going
to be mostly focusing
on MATLAB in this
class and a technology
we call [INAUDIBLE] to
describe that more later.
But this is a
software combination
that allows you to get
relatively good performance
at a significantly
reduced effort,
and that's really the only thing
we're doing in this course.
We're just saying, if you're
doing these types of problems,
there's a right tool
for the job or there
are right tools for
the job, and if you
use the right tool for
the job, it will take you
less time to get the job done.
And we're going to try and
teach you about these tools
and how they actually work.
Now, a little bit of
bait and switch here.
We call the course signal
processing databases,
but we're going to get to
databases at the very end,
unfortunately, to
disappoint you all.
And the reason is
because databases
are good for one
type of problem,
but it's often at the
very end of the game
where you really need
to work with databases.
So to understand, we have
a variety of different ways
we can solve problems
with algorithms, OK.
We can solve our problems
just using a single computer's
memory.
We can solve our
problems using the memory
on multiple computers.
We can solve our problems
using disks or storage, or even
with many disks, OK,
and as we go this way,
we can do more and
more and more data.
But one of the things that
really matters, and it kind of
goes back to that other
chart there is well,
when I'm working with this
data, what is the chunk size?
What are the blocks that
I need to get the data in?
And if I need to get the data
in very, very small chunks,
well then obviously
having the data in memory
is going to be the most
efficient thing I can do.
If I want to just get one
record out of many records,
then that's the most efficient,
having the data in memory.
Likewise-- so that's where
we typically start, right?
If our problem is small when
we almost always try and start
with our problems with small,
we're going to be working here.
We're going to be writing what
we call serial programs on one
computer.
And then, the great
thing about serial memory
is that even as our
requests size gets larger,
they're really not going to
do anything better than just
having the data in memory.
So we'll be able to grow
that model up to data sets
that are fairly small, maybe
gigabytes, and we can continue
to use that model just fine.
And then, if we
decide, well, we're
really moving beyond that,
we need to do more data,
we can go to a parallel
program to get more memory,
or we can use data in files.
We can write our
data to files, we
can read them in, process
them, and read them out,
and that model works
very, very well.
And in fact,
particularly if we're
going to be accessing
the data in large chunks.
If I have a lot
of data and like I
want to do some processing
on the whole piece of it.
Likewise, if we go to
a very large data sets,
we find that we can even do
parallel programs writing files
in parallel if we want to do
extreme large problems that we
want to traverse all the data.
But finally, we're going
to come back to this case
where we need a database.
And a database is when we have
very large amounts of data
but we want to
access-- database,
data that won't
fit in our memory,
but we want to access
in little bits.
We want to look up something.
And that's really the only
time we really need a database,
unless of course someone
says this is your data.
It is available to
you on a database.
That's the only way
you're going to access it.
But if you have
control-- so you always
want to follow this path.
You want to start with
your serial program memory,
maybe go to a parallel
program using files, maybe
parallel files, and then
the database is almost
the two of last
resort because it
adds a great deal of complexity,
and while it can look up
things much quicker, if you
actually end up doing something
where you're going
to be traversing
a significant
fraction of the data,
you will find it's actually
significantly slower
than if you have
the data on files.
So we're going to
show you techniques,
we're going to follow this path,
and then hopefully by the end,
you'll be like,
oh, well yes, now I
know why we use a database
for these instances,
but I realize that
I can get most
of my work done using
these other techniques that
work just fine.
So hopefully you're
going to be learning
what we call the fast path.
So if you want to get a
certain level of performance,
OK, if you have no training
or minimal training,
this is the path
that you follow.
You began using a technology.
Your program gets
slower for a while.
You beat your head against the
wall and the web for a while.
Maybe eventually,
after days, you
get back to where you
were, and then slowly you
climb up here to get it to
some level of performance weeks
later.
This is something we
observe time and time again,
and typically what happens
is that right around here
people just give up
with the technology
and they say the technology
didn't work for them.
The point of this class is
to give you the techniques
that an expert would have.
An expert could
use the technology,
know exactly how to use it,
and then can go on this path
where basically within hours
you're getting good performance
and if they really want to
take it to the next level
they can spend days doing that.
And so that's kind of our
whole philosophy here.
So we're going to actually
have some new concepts
in this course.
I think they're talked
about in the course
outline a little bit, some
of the really new ideas
that you probably wouldn't have
run across in other courses.
So we're going to be
talking about graphs a lot
in this course.
The standard graph
that-- how many people
have taken a graph theory course
or a computer science course
that talked about graphs?
Most.
I'm glad to see linear algebra
is still the stronger one here.
That's more important.
Between the two, having the
linear algebra background
is the more important.
And I can, if you
know linear algebra,
I can teach you graph
theory pretty easily.
The traditional
definitions of graphs,
though, that are taught in
most computer science courses,
they tend to focus
on what we call
undirected, unweighted graphs.
So these are a graph is a
set of vertices and edges,
and so what we're
saying when we say
it's an undirected
and unweighted graph
is that all the edges are the
same between any two vertices.
There's no real
difference between them.
Either an edge
exists or it doesn't.
It's kind of like
a zero or a one.
And then it doesn't
really-- when
we say two vertices
connected, there's
no directionality of that.
The majority of graph theory
and what's taught in class
is based on that.
Excuse me.
Unfortunately, when we
get into the real world--
unfortunately, when we
get into the real world,
we find that I've never
run into that kind of graph
in the real world.
In the years I've
been doing this,
I've never actually run
into that kind of graph.
In fact, another part
of that is they'll
talk about the distribution.
In fact, you'll
often hear something
called an Erdos-Renyi
graph, which
is just a random connection.
It is any two vertices
are randomly connected
with maybe some probability.
And again, I've never run into
that either in the real world.
So the focus of graph
theory that we have now
that we have all this
data and can compare
the theory and
the data, can bury
the theory of the experiment, we
see that the theory is wanting.
The theory is not a good
stepping stone into the data.
And so what we see is that
the real data is not random.
It's often what we call
a power law distribution,
that a certain vertices
are very popular
and most vertices don't have
a lot of connections to them.
Usually the edges are directed,
that is, there's meaning.
If I friend you,
it's not the same
as you friending me on Facebook
or Twitter, or you twit face,
or whatever the technology
is of the future.
Usually the edge of self
has meaning, has weight.
That weight could be of value.
It could be words, it could
be other types of things.
Typically you have
multiple edges.
I could send you
many friend requests.
You know, that's not the
same thing as me sending you
one friend request.
Maybe I can't send
you friend requests.
I have multiple friend requests.
I don't know.
But you can have multiple
edges between vertices.
And probably most
importantly is edges
are often what we
call hyper, and this
is a very important concept
that is almost never touched
on in graph theory, which
is that an edge can connect
multiple vertices
at the same time.
A classic example
would be an email
that you send to
multiple people.
In fact, most emails these days
have more than one recipient.
And so, me sending
an email to everyone
in the class, one email
to everyone in the class,
is a hyper edge.
That edge, the email,
connects and has direction,
you know, me with
all the recipients.
That's very different
than me individually
sending an email to every
single one of you, which
would be a standard edge.
So this is an important concept
not typically discussed a lot
in standard graph theory
that is very important.
So we're going to move beyond
the sort of standard definition
of graphs in this class,
and that's going to be hard.
We're going to
deal with a bigger
definition of linear algebra.
Traditionally, linear algebra
is dealing with matrices.
They have indices for
the rows and the columns
and the values are real numbers.
Maybe integers, may
be complex numbers,
we deal with complex
numbers here a lot,
but we're going to be dealing
with things like strings.
We're going to be
taking linear algebra
and applying it to
things like words.
And so that's going
to be different.
In fact actually,
one of my favorite--
it might be the part
of the course that
puts you all asleep,
but it's actually
one of my favorite
parts of the course.
And then, bigger
definition of processing.
One of the dominant
things you'll
hear about in this
space-- there's
a lot of technologies out there.
A popular technology
is called Hadoop,
and it's map/reduce parallel
programming paradigm, which
is a great technology to
kind of get people started,
but for people with the
mathematical sophistication
that we have, we can
use programming models
that are simply better.
If you understand mathematics
to the level that we do,
we can give you tools for
programming parallel computers
that are just more efficient
in terms of you write less code
and you get better performance
than using techniques that
really are designed for
people that don't have
the mathematical, the
linear algebraic background
that you have.
So this is really going to be
the foundation of the course.
So let me continue here
with the course outline.
So this is going
to be, essentially,
the nine lecture of the course.
I think this is still
pretty accurate.
So we're in the
introductory course,
we're going to review
the course and goals.
The next course is really
going to be dealing
with this concept of
associative arrays, which
is the core technology that sort
of brings all this together.
When I talk about extending
linear algebra to words,
using funny, using, sorry, by
using fuzzy algebra that really
gets into mathematical
abstract algebraic concepts
called group theory.
It's not nearly as
scary as it may sound.
We'll get into that.
It's actually, I
think, quite elegant
and really good to know.
Good to know that when you
work with the technology
and you work with
associative arrays,
that we've actually thought
about the mathematics of how
these things work together.
And when we add a
feature, it's usually
because it fits
mathematically, and when
we don't add a
feature, it's usually
because someone
has made a request
and like, yeah, that's
really going to take people
into a bad place.
Then we're going to get into
really sort of the center
part of the class
where we're going
to show you how we do
analysis of entities
on unstructured data,
and then doing analysis
on unstructured data.
We're going to--I've
talked about power laws.
We' going to whole class
on power law data, modeling
of that deal, but then
we have another class
in cross-correlation,
and then we're
really going to get
into parallel processing
and databases.
And the last two
classes aren't ever
going to really be lecturers.
They're going to be really
just the demos, and really--
because that's where we're going
to really bring a lot of things
together, and we're going to
walk you through code examples,
but we're going to need to take
some time to really walk you
through them, because
you're going to see,
wow, there's all
these ideas that we've
talked about coming together
in these code examples.
So there is, we have lectures.
If you see in the software
that's available in your LLGrid
accounts, all the lectures
are there already,
and I think we have
lectures one through seven.
So seven is the eighth lecture.
Or, I'm sorry, zero
through seven, so seven
is the eighth
lecture, and that will
be a kind of a short lecture.
And then the ninth lecture will
be just going through examples.
So we believe in
this whole philosophy
of taking a linear
algebraic point of view
with graphs so much that we
even wrote a book about it.
So you have all been
given copies of this book.
This really gives you the
philosophy and the power
of if you think about
graphs using the techniques,
so I'd highly encourage
you to flip through it.
There are certain parts of
this, certain sections here
that are really almost taken
directly out of this book,
but a lot of it is
supplementary material.
And what you'll discover is
that this course is really
the bridge to these techniques.
This course allows
you to go from kind
of this mess of
unstructured words
and other types of
things, and then
put them into this nice
linear algebraic format,
so that is now you can
do these techniques that
are described in the book.
So this is almost a bridge
that and I'd certainly
encourage you to look
at that and to ask me
questions about it at any time.
So now I'm going to come back
to our original example, which
was the cyber thing
and kind of walk us
through that in a
little bit more detail
and maybe highlight
a few of the things
that I've talked about already.
So here's a very standard
data processing pipeline.
So we want to do is
we have raw data,
in this case our raw cyber data,
which is a series of records.
And we need to convert that
into a set of vertices and edge
lists from which we can then
do graphs and graphs analysis.
And, as you'll see,
typically what you do
is you write parsers to convert
this data from some raw format
to some format that is
sort of the next step
in your processing chain.
And then we convert
these edge lists
into adjacency matrices, which
is how we view our graphs.
One word on adjacency
matrix, let me go back here.
This is a graph, [LAUGHS] for
those of you who don't know.
The set of vertices
and edges, OK?
And this is an adjacency
matrix of that graph.
Basically every single
row is a vertex,
every single column is
a vertex, and if an edge
exists we put a dot here.
There's a formal duality
between graph theory,
the fundamental
operation of graph theory
is what's called breadth-first
search, which is shown here,
giving a starting vertex.
You know, traverse its
edges to its neighbors,
and we have the same
thing going on here.
Given a starting
vertex in a vector,
we do a matrix multiply
to identify the neighbors.
And so at the deepest, most
fundamental level, graph theory
and linear algebra are linked.
Because the fundamental
operation of graph theory
is breadth-first search and
the fundamental operation
of linear algebra is
vector matrix multiply.
So we wish to form these
adjacency matrices so we
can take advantage of that.
Here's a little bit
more detail on how
we're going to use this
technology D4M to do that.
So we have our raw data,
we convert the raw data
into a CSV file-- stands for
a comma separated value files.
It's kind of the default format
of spreadsheets and tables.
It's become very
popular over the years.
I remember when it first
came out 20 or 30 years ago,
it wasn't that popular.
You know, it's like
people did-- but now it's
become extraordinarily
popular file format.
It really is ideally suited
for this kind of data.
So we convert that
into CSV files.
We then take those
CSV files, read them
in using our D4M
technology to insert them
into a distributed database.
We can then query that
distributed database to get
these associative arrays.
And then we can, from
the associative arrays,
now we have the full power
to do our graph algorithms.
So D4M really helps
you in going, you know,
these few steps and setting the
table so that you can then you
graph algorithms.
And you can even then
do the graph algorithms
without even using D4M at all.
You can just use regular linear
algebraic operations in MATLAB
just fine.
But this is that
bridge, that connector.
In fact, I highly
recommend people do that.
I highly recommend you
use D4M for only the parts
of your problem
that it's good for,
and use other
technologies, you know,
like MATLAB, ordinary matrices,
and other types of things.
That's good for you, you'll
get better performance.
It's good for me because,
if you have problems,
you'll bother somebody
else, and not us.
So that's good, it's
good for everybody.
So an example of kind
of what this looks like.
Here's a proxy log that
we got from the data.
It shows a web, essentially a
web log, the first thing we do
is essentially convert
this into a CSV file.
So basically, each entry
here gets a column,
we have an ID for
the actual entry.
In this case it's a source
IP, a sever IP, a time stamp.
And then, the actual line of
text that's associated with it.
And this can go
on and on and on.
We can have many
different types here.
And if you are a
standard database person,
put your SQL hat, which is sort
of the standard database, on.
You would just take
that data, and you
would make a table that
would have these columns,
and you would insert them
and away you would go up.
OK?
But what we discover is that--
the challenge becomes when you
want to look up data quickly.
Or you want to insert data.
Let's say you have an
enormous volume of data
that you want to
insert and you want
to go to look up any, say, IP
address, or any time stamp,
or something like that.
What you discover is
that SQL might give you
good performance, but there
are databases out there
and technology that will
give you better performance.
And these databases are
called triple stores,
because they store all
the data as-- anyone?
Triples, yes.
They store all the
data as triples,
which means we will have
a row, and a column,
and a value associated
with everything.
So what we do is we
take our dense data,
and we do what we call,
create an exploded table.
So essentially we have the
log ID, let me append that,
and we take the column name
and we append its value to it,
and server IP.
And this is what you would
call an exploded table.
Now, if you're an old
SQL person like me,
this schema will
immediately give you hives,
and other types of
allergic reactions,
and you will want to
go to the hospital,
because you're creating an
enormous number of columns.
And in SQL you where you can
dynamically create columns,
but at your peril.
Basically, you can create
columns dynamically,
but the database
reserves the right
to recopy the entire table,
and reformat the entire table,
if it so requires.
Well triple stores don't
have this requirement.
Triple stores only store
the non-blank entries.
And so they're perfectly happy
with as many columns you want.
If you have a billion rows,
10 billion columns, completely
fine with that.
So that's a powerful thing.
So I think we talked about that.
So we use the indices
as rows, and we
create unique type-value
pairs for every single column.
Now, by itself, this schema
does you absolutely no good.
You basically just
made your life harder,
because, by itself,
most database tables,
database systems,
including triple stores,
are going to have
an orientation.
They're going to be row
oriented, or column oriented.
And in this case, the databases
we will be talking about
are almost always row oriented.
Which means they can get
a row in constant time,
give it a row key like
this and you can look it up
very quickly.
And it will give it back
to you very quickly.
That's what it's design to do.
And you can insert
enormous volumes of data,
and they will preserve
that contract.
You can be inserting millions
of entries per second,
and you can still look
up stuff in milliseconds.
So very powerful technology,
but all we've done so far
has made it so that
the format of my data
is in this funny format,
coming out the other side.
I've just made myself harder.
Well, there is a payoff,
which is we also store
the transpose of the table.
So, to anybody who is used
to sparse linear algebra,
this is an old
ancient technique.
We almost always store
A and A transpose,
because in sparse
linear algebra we'll
either have a row oriented
or column based store.
And then we just want
to keep one around
because certain operations
are going to be faster
with the transpose,
and certain operations
are going to be faster
with the matrix.
We do the exact same
thing here, and combined
with our exploded schema,
now every single one
of those columns is a row.
And now we have indexed
every single string
in the entire database.
Once, with one simple
schema of two tables.
And not to say that all
your databases will only
have two tables, but they
might be three tables or four
tables-- is typically
what we see,
which is a huge
reduction compared
to the standard database
schemas that one
uses where it's easy to have
dozens and dozens of tables,
even 100 of tables in a
well thought out schema.
Here, essentially it's one
schema to rule them all.
One table and its
pair, and you've
indexed every single thing.
And the cost is, you've
doubled your storage.
And every single
database person that you
talk to-- if I said in exchange
for doubling your storage I
would give you a fast index
access to every single string
in your database,
they'll usually
take that deal 100
times out of 100.
So that's the power
here of this technology,
is you can reference
enormous data sets.
And we'll come back to this
schema over and over again.
But that's sort of the madness.
We'll be-- as we move forward
with associate arrays we always
view things in this way.
And I want you to
know, at the end,
there's a really good
reason why we do that.
So now we've ingested our
data into the database
and we can do queries.
So if I have a binding
to a table-- and one
of the things in the
deformed technology
that we do that's
very nice for you,
is if you're using a
table and its transpose,
we hide that for you completely.
If you do an insert
into the table,
it will automatically
insert its transpose.
And if you do a look-up on rows,
it will know to use one table,
and it does a
look-up on columns,
it will know to use
the other table.
So here we're doing
essentially a range query.
This just says give me all
the data from this range.
Time stamp May
whatever to, it looks
like about a 3 hour time window.
So that's a query
into the database,
and it returns an
associative array of keys.
And here is what
that looks like.
It looks like a
bunch of triples.
I'm going to then take
the rows of those keys.
So basically I found
every single row,
within a particular
time stamp, and I
want to get the whole row.
So I can get the row of that and
pass that back into the table
to get the actual data.
Now you see I get the whole row.
So I get server IP, and all
that stuff, the complete list.
Now I'm going to do a
little algebra here.
I want to create the graph.
It's all source
IPs and server IPs.
I get to do this with this
basically correlation here,
which is essentially a
matrix-matrix multiply.
That's it, I've just constructed
the entire source IP and server
IP graph from all the
data in this time window.
That is the power of D4M.
It allows you to do correlations
on this kind of data,
same way we do correlations
using traditional techniques
in linear algebra.
And you can be like, "Wow."
This is motivational
at this point.
We'll get into exactly
how you do this,
and exactly how this
works in the example.
But this is really
what people use
D4M for, is to get to
this point where can do
these types of manipulations.
And the key to deduction
theory is doing correlations.
Correlations allow
us to determine
what the backgrounds
of our data are,
what the clutter
and then we are on our way
with traditional detection
theory, and signal processing
techniques, and all the things
that we know we love.
So this is kind of that
connection made manifest.
And so here you can see, we
now have an associative array
or an adjacency matrix that
eventually, essentially
sorts IPs and their server IPs.
You can actually
plot that and that's
how we get the adjacency
matrix of this graph,
G. This is what it is.
That's how we constructed--
this is the code we actually
used to construct that graph.
So moving on here.
So this just shows the kind
of the whole thing here.
We had a whole week's
worth of proxy data.
This just shows you the timing,
that it took about two hours
to ingest it, and about three
hours to do this processing.
100 million proxy logs,
44.5 billion triples.
This is big data.
You know, really
this is big data.
This is the kind of
thing that you can do.
Whatever anybody
else is doing, you
should be able to do on larger
scales than other people
using this technology.
So that brings us to
the end of the lecture.
So just to summarize,
big data of this type
is found in a wide range of
areas, document analysis,
computer networks,
DNA sequencing.
There's a kind of a
gap between the tools
that people traditionally
use to do this problem,
and D4M, this technology,
fills this gap.
So, with that, are
there any questions
before we get onto
the examples slide?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEREMY KEPNER: Yes.
JEREMY KEPNER: So the data--
AUDIENCE: Can you
repeat the question?
JEREMY KEPNER: Oh
yes, the question
was does it generalize to
multi-dimensions, I guess?
And so, there may be kind
of two questions there.
If you had-- if I just
correlated all the data,
took that table out, and
just fully correlated it,
I would end up
with a giant matrix
of blocks, each one representing
different correlations.
So the source IP, server IP
correlation, the source IP,
source IP correlation,
which would be empty
because it's a bipartite graph.
And then all the
other correlations
would form different blocks,
and that type of thing.
So in that sense we
support multi-dimensions.
Whether we support-- but
supporting multi-dimensions
in terms of tensors, OK?
Well, generally in
sparse linear algebra,
there's very minimal support
for higher dimensions.
I'll put a little shout
out to my friend Tammy
Kolda, who has a technology
called the Sparse Tensor
Toolbox.
She's a scientist at Sandia and
so I encourage you to do that.
But all of our stuff
is in two dimensions
from a linear
algebra perspective.
Also linear
algebraically, the math
there is a little bit
more common than when
you get into the tensor.
And then you have these
kind of weird products
that you're starting, which
you can define, but are just
not commonly taught.
So and you might be
like, well you're really
losing something there.
I'd really like to have
multiple dimensions.
Well, when we've looked at
it, the fact of the matter
is the sparsity always increases
as you go to higher dimensions.
And the sparsity
is sparse enough.
So typically the
kinds of data that we
will have-- if you
have n vertices,
you'll have maybe
10 times n edges.
So the sparsity
is extremely low.
We added a dimension.
This sort of internal
data structure costs
associated with adding
that dimension would not
reap the benefits.
Because now your
sparsity is even lower.
And so that's
generally not something
that is commonly used.
But, if you're
interested exploring that
I certainly encourage people
to download that toolbox.
Very well written software,
and people can explore that.
Other questions?
That was an
outstanding question.
And other questions
at this time?
All right well why don't
we stop the recording
right now, and then we
will switch-- why don't we
take like a five minute break.
I think there's some water out
there and stuff for people.
And then we'll get back to
the examples, which probably
will be a lot more fun.
So hopefully wake you up
after these new graphs.